welcome to our press conference
following the eu china summit
we will be releasing our press
communique very shortly president you
have the floor
ladies and gentlemen good afternoon
everyone we have just concluded our eu
china summit
today's summit is not business as usual
because this is a wartime summit
we are living through the gravest
security crisis in europe since world
war ii
putin's role in ukraine continues to
kill women and children and destroy
entire cities
and this is a blatant violation of
international law the european union's
top priority is to stop the war as soon
as possible and to protect the ukrainian
people
in times of crisis
dialogue is needed more than ever
that's why we focused on what can be
done to end this war as soon as possible
the eu and china will agree
that this war is threatening global
security and the world's economy
this global instability is not in
china's interest and not in the eu's
interest
we share a responsibility as double
actors to work for peace and stability
we called on china to help end the war
in ukraine
china
cannot turn a blind eye to russia's
violation of international law and these
principles are enshrined in the u.n
charter and principled
sacred to china
the eu together with our international
partners we have imposed heavy sanctions
on russia
and our goal is to put pressure on the
kremlin and to end the war
these sanctions
have also a price for us in europe but
this is the price to defend freedom and
democracy
any attempts
to circumvent
sanctions
or provide aid to russia would prolong
the war
this would lead to more loss of life and
greater economic impact
this is not in anyone's long-term
interest
we will also remain vigilant on any
attempts to aid russia financially or
militarily
however positive steps by china to help
and the wall would be welcomed by all
europeans and by the global community
we also discussed
areas of shared interests where we
cooperate like global health we want to
engage with china and all members of the
who on a new agreement on pandemic
prevention preparedness and response
we are also cooperating with china to
protect our planet and we can and we
must do more we must be ready for club
27 in egypt later this year and we also
told on china to further increase its
ambition on environment biodiversity and
timed action
we also distrust areas
where we disagree
we raised our concerns about china's
treatment of minorities in chinese
and inner mongolia and of the people of
tibet
and this includes the crackdown on human
rights defenders
we also expressed a regret at the
dismantling of the one country to
systems in hong kong
and we insisted a lot on the relaunch of
the human rights dialogue and prime
minister literacy confirmed that this
would take place the relaunch of the
human rights dialogue we also raised
individual human rights cases
we also discussed our trade and economic
relationship with china to make it
fairer to ensure reciprocity to achieve
a level playing field to rebalance our
bilateral trade and investment relations
we also raised the issue of china's
discriminatory trade practices against
lithuania and the effects for the
integrity of the single market we also
touched on a number of international
issues
taiwan of course the importance of
preserving stability and the state used
through in the taiwan strait the
challenges in afghanistan but also the
situation in myanmar and the
[Music]
madam president thank you very much um
indeed today's summit was certainly not
business as usual it took place in a
very sober atmosphere
it took place against the backdrop of
the russian wars still unraveling the in
ukraine
and thus it was good that we had a very
open and very frank exchange today with
president president xi and prime
minister lee
it was clear that this is not only a
defining moment for our continent
but it is also a defining moment
for our relationship with the rest of
the world
looking at the facts on the ground in
ukraine the suffering of the citizens
the shelling and the bombing of cities
the millions forced to flee
it is clear that this is a humanitarian
disaster that was created by choice
we are supporting ukraine and its people
as they face an unjustified aggression
the war is also a violation on common
principles and rules and first and
foremost on the u.n charter
an overwhelming majority of u.n members
stand united in condemning russia's
aggression against ukraine there must be
respect for international law
as well as for ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity
and therefore
china
as a permanent member of the u.n
security council
has a very special responsibility
this is what we discussed in a very
frank and open manner
we the european union are determined to
support the multilateral order
together with our international partners
we have taken action we have adopted
massive sanctions that are effective
more than 40 countries are
total in total have joined these
sanctions
so we also made very clear that china
should
if not support
at least not interfere with our
sanctions
we discussed that and also the fact that
no european citizen would understand any
support
to russia's ability to wage war
moreover
it would lead to a major reputation of
reputational damage for china here in
europe
the reputational risks are also driving
forces in the exodus of international
companies from russia
the business sector is watching very
closely the events and evaluating how
countries are positioning themselves
this is a question of trust
of reliability and of course of
decisions on long-term investments
let me remind you that every day china
and the european union trade almost 2
billion euros worth of goods and
services and in comparison
trade between china and russia is only
300 some 330 million euros per day
so a prolongation of the war and the
disruptions it brings to the world
economy
is therefore in no one's interest
certainly not in china's
beyond the russian invasion in ukraine
and its consequences we of course also
discussed bilateral issues
we continue to cooperate constructively
on climate issues
we want to build on this to prepare for
cop27 and shameless shake
the current high prices for fossil fuels
are also important to watch because they
should not bring us
to allow a lock in in fossil fuels but
they should on the contrary move us
forward towards more strategic
investment in renewables and investment
in a decarbonized economy
we can also cooperate in the fight
against covet i've always said that we
are in for long haul
and to set the record straight i think
figures always count also over time
the european union is the world's
front-runner
when it comes to providing vaccines to
the world
to date the european union has exported
over 2 billion doses of vaccines
of which over 400 million are donated
85 through covex
china and comparison has exported 1.2
billion doses
and donated 115 million doses
bilaterally and via kovacs 220 million
doses
of course we acknowledge that omicron is
hitting china hard
thirty percent of its economy and twenty
five percent of its population are in
lockdown right now
so we have a mutual interest in ensuring
widespread vaccination with the
effective mrna vaccine technology to
stop the pandemic
we see by experience here in europe that
the best protection against omicron's
impact is full vaccination and boosters
in europe 70 percent of the population
are fully vaccinated and 52 are boosted
and we're always willing to share
expertise and support in this matter
with china
but we also made clear to china that a
number of important differences need to
be addressed
china must stop its unjustified trade
measures against lithuania
which violate wtao rules and disrupt the
eu's internal market
until it does we will pursue our case in
front of the wto
china must also lift its sanctions
against members of the european
parliament it must address global
concerns on human rights and labor
rights in particular as concerns
the situation in young region
and we need a level playing field in our
trade and investment relations
china needs to improve the access and
conditions for our companies on the
chinese market so to conclude
this summit was an important opportunity
for us to convey europe's deep concerns
about russia's war and aggression
against ukraine
and our determination not to let it
stand
and we know the world has taken a very
clear stance on this thank you very much
thank you madam president
we'll take a few questions first here in
the room stuart your first
political
thank you baron stewart now from
politico my first question goes to
president michelle so right now in your
opening remarks you talked about keeping
vigilance on any attempt by any
countries to aid russia financially or
militarily
did you receive any assurance from
chinese leaders today that they wouldn't
do that
and if they do if any country does what
would the eu's reaction be
and for president on the line a month
ago in munich security conference you
raised concerns about the china-russia
partnership agreement signed just a few
weeks before the war started after
today's summit did you get any assurance
from china that you know the same
position might have altered or are you
still keeping the same position on this
concern and if this persists what should
you do thank you
first first element it was extremely
important to have a candidate a very
open exchange of views on the current
situation for obvious reasons because we
all understand that this situation is
extremely serious extremely dangerous
not only for for europe but also for for
the rest of the world this is one first
element second element we share some
goals we want peace we want prosperity
we want uh security third point
during the last european council meeting
here in brisbane in brussels
we have taken important decision we have
decided to deal with the commission to
make
all the possible efforts in order to
avoid being collectively victims of
loopholes and that's why we engage
politically diplomatically in order to
explain our arguments and we think
indeed and this what you have explained
to the chinese authorities this is
important to put pressure on the
trembling it's also important to
encourage the kremlin to negotiate and
to be sincere in those tools we have
we have had this occasion to use all
possible arguments arguments that are
well known here in europe and we hope we
hope that those arguments have been
hurt by the chinese authorities
so both sides emphasized the importance
of the peace architecture we have
i think for us is very important
that we always keep in mind and
insist on the fact that we have
a clear multilateral order that has been
developed
by the world's community because of the
atrocities of the last century
and therefore it is in no one's interest
to try to redefine that
in that we've been very clear
and there's a second point where we've
been very clear in this summit too that
this is a defining moment not only for
europe
but also for the rules-based order
it is a defining moment because nothing
will be
like it was before the war
it's now a question to
take a very clear stance
to
support and defend
the rules-based order which is very
clear that if you have conflicts you
sold them at the negotiation table you
don't
take
aggressive military actions and
therefore it is for us important that
regions countries actors on the global
stage
are very clear on that too that they
support this peace architecture that is
built on negotiations and not on
military aggressive action
philippe regnier
[Music]
i think we have very clearly
defined our if i could frame it manifold
relationship to china
and you know
the three elements indeed there are
constructive parts they are competitive
parts and there are clear rivalry parts
in it
and today it was very important
first of all that
we explained the european position and
what it means
to have
such a war
here on european soil
we know that
in china right now the focus is much
much more on omicron and covet
the lockdowns they have the complete
lockdowns
the focus is much more on the need to
create jobs and to tackle the housing
crisis
therefore it was very important to
signal
what paramount importance
this war has for europe but also for the
global security architecture
and that equidistance
is not enough
that
active engagement for peace is important
and that each player should play its
role
and therefore this exchange of views
was of utmost importance for us
yuri you have the last question
deutsche welle
so thank you very much eurasia
kodacheval i have two questions first
you describe this exchange with chinese
as open and frank but we know that china
doesn't call
russian aggression as ukraine as a war
it calls its ukrainian crisis or
ukrainian issue so can you explain how
is it possible to conduct a franklin and
open discussion with someone who doesn't
call a big
full-fledged war a war how is it
possible to talk then with them and the
second question i should still ask again
what my colleague asked did you hear
anything or what did you hear from the
chinese side
uh when you asked china not to support
russia either literally or economically
to circumvent sanctions what did you
hear with them any assurances or nothing
at all thank you very much
yes indeed frank and open means that we
exchange very clearly opposing views
this is not a conflict this is a war
this is not a european affair
this is
a global affair
it concerns the whole world
and this is russia that unleashes all
the knock-on effects for example
the looming food security crisis
for the world
of course as i said it's opposing views
and this is frank and open if you are
able to exchange that and we did that
the second point is
that of course we expect china as a
member of the security council of the
united nation
to take its responsibilities
there are few members only and they have
a vast responsibility and china has an
influence on russia and therefore we
expect china to take its responsibility
to end this war
and to come back that russia comes back
to a peaceful negotiations
solution
and last but not least this was part of
your question too of course we expect
china if not supporting the sanctions
at least to do everything
not to interfere in any kind also on
that point we were very clear
thank you madam president mr president
this concludes our press conference keep
an eye out for our press release which
is coming soon thank you for joining us